[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga DWS
international talk show coming to you
from Berlin I'm Brian Thomas and on our
show today you've seen them for about
three months now every weekend out on
the streets of Hong Kong thousands of
protesters calling for democracy and the
rule of law at one protest 1.7 million
people peacefully staking their claim on
freedom police holding back this time
with no tear gas and no rubber bullets
but will Beijing give Hong Kong the
freedom and autonomy it so desperately
wants and why is the West been so
reluctant to unequivocally back up the
protesters and their calls for democracy
our topic today China's power play Hong
Kong betrayed to talk about this I'm
joined by Wally from DWS Asia desk he
says China wanted to experiment with a
rule of law and democracy in Hong Kong
with one country two systems and now
also has to make concessions
Bernard Bosch is a senior expert on Asia
for the Bertelsmann foundation base here
in Berlin he says Hong Kong is the
epicenter of a global competition of
systems Western democracies should show
solidarity and resilience and the
ability to learn and cherry Chan is from
Hong Kong works for DW social media team
in Berlin she says China's propaganda
war is only uniting the people of Hong
Kong and they will not stop fighting on
the streets until they get a real
response from the government thanks so
much to all of you for being here today
and to our viewers of course from around
the world as well Wow
if we could start with you you know you
say that it's it's all a matter of of
the people talking in in Hong Kong and
of Beijing experimenting with this city
have they lost control of the laboratory
the laboratory that is right
Hong Kong right now for the Chinese
government are and are events taking on
a life of their own
there wasn't serious out of control to
Beijing never controls Hong Kong in the
real meaning but it's not the culture of
the public image an international word
the situation in Hong Kong is like it is
Hong Kong trying to be the part of the
one country two systems' be the part of
the one of the two systems and what they
demanding a democracy and rule of law is
written in the law and that's what the
domani but Beijing is not ready to give
them the freedom okay to two countries
to two systems one country and one of
the systems is clearly totalitarian the
one in Beijing Hong Kong has been free
to this point a Bernard you say that
Hong Kong's on its way to becoming a
police state at least the police have
played a role in the last couple of
weeks that I think has surprised a lot
of Hong Kong us because in Hong Kong
there was a lot of trust in institutions
and the police and the the police
violence that we've seen and that hasn't
been independently researched is
something that has shocked Hong Kong
Kong Hong Kong us and is really at the
heart of this conflict
now which for Hong Kong is and cherry
knows better than we all do is a
conflict about what is our city going to
be like in the future is it going to be
just any Chinese city or is it going to
remain in a different system okay let's
point out for our viewers that it's 2047
right that Hong Kong reverts to complete
Chinese rule so there's this window of
opportunity there a cherry as a Hong
Kong or how is this city different from
the rest of China born and raised in
Hong Kong Hong Kong people I'm from
there and then we always see freedom
it's almost the same standard as how the
Western world is seeing it we also know
people from China we're friends from
mainland China and when we thought when
we discuss we know that we have a
difference when we look at freedom for
example we always have a relatively high
freedom of speech freedom of media we
can get access to Facebook
on Twitter and the internet without any
restrictions which is very different
from the mainland China okay and it's
also the court systems as well Hong Kong
has been so successful because it has an
independent court system there is the
rule of law that is also a main
difference along with freedom of
expression isn't it yeah exactly in Hong
Kong we always trust our judicial system
and we know that it's independent from
the administration we know we have
always trust that the government would
not intervene easily into any judicial
process or any judicial decisions okay
so it's a long way from where we are
today to a police state that so many
people fear how one of the problems that
Hong Kong protesters have been pointing
to is the extradition law that the
citizens of Hong Kong if they are
charged with the crime would disappear
to mainland China basically what's
behind these fears of being extradited
to mainland China why is that so
terrifying for Hong Kong people about
the reason is pretty clear because Hong
Kong is in city ruled by law but the
mainland China it is not the case
therefore some kirino's accused in Hong
Kong the if they extra if they go to to
mainland China their fear is not a very
transparency proceed in the court that's
the main reason for the whole
participant but now this bill is deaths
as Carrie Lam the CEO of the country but
it's just the beginning of the long
protests because what the finally
demands it's a democracy in a real
meaning like we understand here in West
mmm-hmm
what what do you think Bernard what are
the chances that this real democracy is
how I put it as we you know in the West
can be protected by Carrie Lam the
current leader of the city of Hong Kong
I don't think promoting democracy is the
job that Carrie Lam has been given by
the Beijing government the basic law
said that potentially Hong Kong could
have free elections it's not very
definite if it's a it's an unclear law
but that is what Hong Kong people have
been hoping for the longest time that at
one point there will be
full democracy and baiting has made it
very clear in the last couple of years
that that is not going to happen
and it's Carrie lambs job to now
squash these protests speaking says it
could happen but your Hong Kong he says
it should happen because in the basic
law it says eventually and gradually it
would happen not potentially so we
believe that in the end it would happen
and we're looking forward to this
okay Chery I'm you also pointed to
earlier social media that's a very much
part of China's propaganda warfare aimed
at not only the people inside Hong Kong
but the mainland Chinese as well it
shows that Beijing really wants to get a
control of this process the protest
process as quickly as possible is there
a fear in Beijing and how this question
would apply to use well that that the
protests will will leave Hong Kong and
move to other parts of the country that
we could see protests elsewhere in China
as a result yeah I think the propaganda
war by China is not very obviously not
very successful in Hong Kong and it's
not very successful in the international
media as well because Hong Kong people
have been very used to this kind of
propaganda or state media their
statements and Hong Kong people mainly
use it mainly see it as a joke more than
believing what they are saying yeah so
and also Hong Kong people are really
trying actually they are really trying
to get international attention and there
are lots of protests organized in other
countries as you said how but could the
social media propaganda and other
propaganda lead to protests that will
move to other parts of China or do you
think that's that's a situation that's
to be excluded that these protests are
not transferable to the Weig ours for
example the minority Muslims I don't
think they're going to move somewhere
not any other Chinese cities because
it's not going to work because the Chong
Kong is still a free city you may go to
Street and demonstration but in China
the simple ways we don't know exactly
what happened you haven't really
happened in mainland China we don't know
what exactly happened why it happens and
the police have a very strong hand
we'll make you disappear for a long
period and that's this very risk risk
for all the participant okay we're going
to focus more now on the propaganda war
being waged on numerous of fronts by
Beijing those fronts include global
social media platforms state-run media
from entertainment to films through
internet news sites and of course to
state-run TV as well this is how chinese
state media are presenting the situation
in Hong Kong as a city in chaos with
masked protesters prepared for violence
who may accuse of being bandits and
terrorists this is the Chinese
government's take on the temporary
occupation of Hong Kong Airport we
express our strongest condemnation of
this near terrorist act and express our
deepest condolences to the injured
mainland compatriots and Hong Kong
police the newspapers are also full of
images of violence this propaganda seems
to be plausible for some citizens I
think that it's okay to take to the
streets and protest in a normal way but
you shouldn't destroy public order and
carry out violent acts only terrorists
do that kind of thing state media have
also been showing these images of troop
exercises in san jen on the border with
hong kong but will China really resort
to arms to crush the resistance in Hong
Kong
Bernard what do you think about Chinese
a propaganda aimed at Hong Kong and the
rest of China how effective is it and
it's different isn't it we heard from
cherry that's not very effective in Hong
Kong what about on mainland China do
people buy all of it that's the big
question I think the interesting thing
and you pointed to that is that in Hong
Kong it doesn't work and it doesn't work
although there's been more than 20 years
of strong propaganda strong propaganda
in schools and it didn't work and I
think this demonstration came as a
surprise to Beijing because Beijing
thought we have this covered so the big
question in mainland China is do people
believe all the propaganda yes in a way
they do it's what they're fed with but
it doesn't mean that they are happy with
the system that they're happy with their
own lives and that there's not a lot of
undercurrent of dissatisfaction that
could blow up nobody had a protest like
in Hong Kong on their books and the big
question for Beijing is how is it going
to control its own population okay how
what do you think what is China not
getting right about Hong Kong why is the
propaganda not succeeding there is it
simply that Hong Kong people have access
to Western media is that what's going on
there there's another thing trynna is
which is very good it's like a metaphor
for this reason because the the Asian
Chinese when intellectuals were writing
from upstairs to downstairs when they
are reading old books it's always hmm
why Hong Kong I see a Hong Kong regard
Hong Kong's part of missile there right
from left to the right hand side is
overseas no and just in Beijing right
into the body's response and how we read
that's exactly that's they know
everything what the party in the States
say it's true and they didn't have the
second source an independent source
because of censorship that's the reason
and I don't think the Chinese state-run
media is going to have the control they
might have a culture of the public opini
within the mainland China but what they
want is having an international
opinion a China friendly international
opinion what they are trying to flood
older the Facebook and Twitter okay a
cherry what do you think if propaganda
is not going to work what are the
options for Beijing to get Hong Kong in
line to answer all the demands of Hong
Kong people first of all this is I think
in every mind of Hong Kong citizens they
know very well what they want and what
they are fighting for and they are not
going to stop until they get the demands
answered and also there's one thing to
point out about media in public opinions
in China and maybe Chinese government
think that they could control the public
opinion but the fact is that Chinese
people they are so afraid to speak out
that it's never we are never able to get
what they're really thinking because
they cannot speak on social media they
cannot speak on camera so maybe they are
really thinking like Hong Kong people as
well but it's just that they can never
speak out maybe they want the same
freedoms but we simply don't know that
ok well the Chinese Communist Party's
track record on respecting human rights
is of course dismal the occupation of
Tibet destruction of its culture the
internment of over a million Uighur
Muslims of course as well and the bloody
suppression of the democracy movement at
Tiananmen Square in 1989 now this was
the central point of Beijing's efforts
to crush the human rights movement
thirty years ago and it was a savage
reality when tanks literally rolled over
young pressors protesters in the square
of heavenly peace we all we all remember
that in Tiananmen Square young men and
women who had the audacity just like the
courageous citizens of Hong Kong today
to call for their voices to be heard
that their voices matter just as much as
the highest functionary in the Communist
Party and that all people must be equal
before the law that was what it was all
about back then and is now and the
question is those voice those voices
thirty years ago they were drowned out
in blood we haven't heard them since
then not in the way that we're hearing
them now at least in Hong Kong it's a
big question I know but after looking at
the images of Tiananmen Square from 30
years ago burner if we could start with
you should we be concerned about the
possibility of another Tiananmen Square
in Hong Kong I think we should be
concerned but I don't think it's very
likely gentleman is still a trauma for
the Chinese Communist Party Beijing
knows that it would be drastic if the
PLA the People's Liberation Army
actually went into Hong Kong and I don't
think it's necessary nowadays because
the party has different means of putting
people under pressure it has all the
technical means it has the companies
that are being put under a lot of
pressure now Cathay Pacific and many
others so I don't see a big likelihood
at the same time I don't see a very good
outcome for the Hong Kong people that's
going to be a very unhappy ending I'm
very unhappy ending okay what do you
think that means Gerry what would be a
very unhappy ending have you excluded as
Bernard has the possibility of another
Tiananmen Square
I think Hong Kong people they're very
well aware that China is trying to scare
Hong Kong people with violence and the
possibility of sending an army I think
many of them just try to ignore the fact
or even if they know about this they
would think that they have nothing to
lose if it ends up like this they would
they would take other action then but
then for now the only demand is to have
answers from the government
what do you think oh I don't I don't
think this it's Java square it have been
again with China 30 years ago is was
complete different from
China today because China says always
says it's now a responsible big nation
on the international word and they're
going to use force because under
international conflict China always says
we are peaceful meaning to solve the
problem they can be that China says when
I have a problem my home in backyard I
just make my soldier I sent my soldier
to give it clear that just no problem
anymore this is not unreasonable and
another argument is China is going to
celebrate 60 years founding of the
People's Republic China on beginning of
October that's coming up yeah I don't
believe they're going to be have a very
very bad image in the international
press when the PRA is marching to Hong
Kong okay so China plays a very long
game though the Communist Party in
Beijing if we look at the past if we
look at what's happened in Tibet and
what happened at Tiananmen Square the
internment of the week ORS I mean
Beijing is not adverse to reverting to
force at the end of the day it couldn't
work because Hong Kong has another legal
framework this is a part of another
system the legal framework says the PRA
could be sent to Hong Kong if the see
the leader of Hong Kong officially asked
Beijing to do that but I'm not sink
Carrie Lam is a leader of the city is
going to do that okay well how is the
West respond there's been a mixed
response French and German leaders have
called for dialogue about the situation
the US Congress has condemned China's
heavy-handed police response President
Trump has called on the Chinese
President to exercise restraint I'd like
to see Hong Kong worked out at a very
humanitarian fashion I hope President Xi
can do it he sure has the ability I can
tell you that from personal knowledge he
certainly has the ability to do it if he
wants to so I'd like to see that worked
out in the humanitarian fashion I think
it would be very good for the trade deal
that we're talking about
sorry I believe it's only Donald Trump
who's responded to this in terms of a
high level of world politician is the
u.s. the only country they can bring
pressure to bear on Beijing
I think Hong Kong people are trying to
to ask the international community not
only not not only only the US but also
the EU also Germany England to put
pressure on China but they are also very
well aware that only like if it's only
words it wouldn't really work like what
even if International Committee it's
condemning China if there are no other
action for example economic sanctions or
reaction their words wouldn't mean
anything okay what do you think
expressing concerns kind of pressure and
China has desirous taken take taking to
consider as anxious not a way out single
way out would be that Beijing Hong Kong
they're going to negotiate in the
framework of one country two systems'
about the way a timetable at least how
the Democrat democracy could be
implemented in Hong Kong like Derek like
a general election
okay now we're not listening to cherry
though that's already been decided it's
2047 when China is Surya zooms control
of Hong Kong until then the Chinese
people or the people of Hong Kong rather
want democracy the way I'm hearing you
is that sherry that's non-negotiable
yeah because for us we don't believe
what we're trying to ask for is the
extension of one country to system we
don't want to believe that by 2040 seven
we will become just another city of
China we want to have an extension we
want to have the two system forever
okay the two system forever let's take a
listen now to some of the protesters and
what they have to say about their hopes
their fears and their dreams Franco the
more we come out to protest the more
people will be arrested but we still
will not leave until we get what we want
[Music]
during these two months we lost a lot of
time lots of lots of money in those and
also health because of expired tear gas
but we can easily recover from the harm
of teachers we can cut back on money but
if we use is what Hong Kong's democracy
with
we share the same values as US and EU
that will fight for democracy with fight
for justice and so we hope those
countries can stand up and speak up
alcohol okay after listening to those
protesters are what we're seeing in Hong
Kong or is it something that's shaping
up to be another clash of cultures on
one side it clearly a one-party
ideological system on the other a
multiparty democracy that supports the
rule of law is this a clash of cultures
that we're seeing take place focused on
Hong Kong that has to do with China I'd
prefer the term competition of systems
none of us has an interest in a real
clash but we're definitely in a global
situation where we have the established
Western democracies on the one end on
the other hand we have a rise of
authoritarianism led by China and that
is part of the conflict that is playing
out there that is part of why the u.s.
is getting involved on a high level
because the US and China have this trade
and everything else war going on
so more trouble for Xi Jinping is
something that Donald Trump obviously
enjoys but it's also something that
concerns us in Europe because in Hong
Kong we say we see the PlayBook that
China is using to handle descend and and
calls for democracy and that is a much
much broader question how is it more of
a clash or a competition and I prefer
the word of the term coexisting because
the system should be coexisted in what
China doesn't want is that this between
the one or two systems that one system
is challenging another it should be a
coexistence that says they keep this
hope one country stable okay so cherries
the West's approach right now a good one
should the West back off avoid provoking
China not looking like it's being
involved in the protests right now
speaking from the perspective of a Hong
Kong person of course we would
the West to speak out more to give more
pressure to China but then maybe it's
not in the best interest of all these
Western countries because of all the
other reasons because of economy because
of trade but then if we are just
speaking about the value of democracy
and freedom then obviously the Western
world has this responsibility to stand
up how should the how should the West
there not stay up stand up what does it
need to do to show to the rest of the
world that it indeed believes in the
values on which it's based I think
showing solidarity is important I think
honesty is also important I would be
very happy for leading European
politicians to come out and say we
support this this is a legitimate show
of concern by the Hong Kong people China
is trying to undermine the legitimacy of
these protests and we should show no
this is legitimate and on the other hand
we should also be very open and saying
you can't you can expect this from us
but you can't expect more
we have interests in China we are in a
very different very difficult situation
this is how far we can support you but
please see the complicated situation
that we're in okay last question to you
do you think this is going to end
peacefully you you're promoting a
coexistence of the two systems is it
going to end well I believe they're
going to end well because the single way
out is then the solution between Hong
Kong Beijing and that's they have to the
homework they have to do right now and
sit down at the table and start talking
that's right sherry we could talk more
some point about extending the freedoms
past 2047 we're out of time though I'd
like to thank all of our viewers from
around the world for joining us on
quadriga today and of course our guests
here as well
I'm Brian Thomas for all of us thanks so
much for being with us today
[Music]